spiders don't just use their silk
threads to build webs they also spin
sails to catch the breeze
sometimes flying hundreds of kilometers
this behavior called ballooning has
helped spiders dispersed all over the
globe to find out more about how spiders
launch scientists in Germany collected
some large orb webs spinning crab
spiders in a park outside Berlin they
put the spiders on a mushroom-shaped
platform outdoors and observed how the
spiders behaved under different wind
conditions they also put the arachnids
in a wind tunnel where the scientists
could carefully control wind speed and
temperature the spiders didn't release
their silk balloons at random
instead they tested the wind by raising
their front legs in the air for about
six seconds when it was cold and windy
the spiders head but when the breeze was
warm and gentle less than three meters
per second the spiders spun out a
triangular sail made of silk threads
spiraling updrafts lifted the sails and
the spiders were on their way it's clear
these crab spiders wait for the right
conditions before takeoff the next
question is can they control where they
land
[Music]